alors bonsoir Je m'appelle Louis José je
suis un homme blanc de 40 ans
hétérosexuel vous allez animer votre 17e
gala de la disque dimanche et là j'ai
l'impression que vous allez gérer le
trafic cette année parce qu'il y a ceux
qui vont se plaindre des apôts de ce
monde il y en a d'autres qui vont se
plaindre de l'annulation du galet cinéma
comment vous allez composer avec tout ça
en tant qu'animateur il y a toujours un
peu de trafic avant le gala certaines
années plus que d'autres mais je déteste
pas quand il y a un petit peu comme ça
de quand ça se met par l'effort une
semaine avant 10 jours avant l'événement
je trouve que ça met un peu de vie
là-dedans ça donne une portée au galop
qui est intéressant puis après ça moi je
passe un message de paix et de et je me
lance pas non plus dans une tirade là de
déception le face au retrait du Gala
cinéma Québec
animateur de ce genre de soirée là ça me
désole un peu de voir ça
votre humour vous il est gentil quand
même mais lorsque vous avez Will Smith
monter sur scène qu'avez-vous pensé de
tout ça parce que vous êtes humoriste
nécessairement vous étiez dans la peau
de cross évidemment je mentionne ça
cette année dans monologue
c'est ce qui s'est passé cette fois-là
et autres fois le cette année ça a quand
même bouger un peu sur les scènes et
puis non je me sens toujours vraiment
sécurité je pense pas je pense qu'au
Québec on est cette
cette énergie cette volonté de se faire
justice comme ça
devant le monde
vous avez présenté il y a 20 ans votre
tout premier spectacle 300 000 billets
vendus 500 représentations plusieurs
humoristes de l'époque ont eu de la
difficulté à s'adapter à cette montée
vite parce que beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup de rencontres après les
spectacles vous commencez
bonne question je
c'est un mélange de peut-être de mes
racines là
j'avais des parents j'ai toujours des
parents là qui étaient extrêmement
raisonnable à leur place et plein de
sens puis qui m'inculquer ça et puis qui
nous a toujours de rester
sobre et modeste dans la mesure du
possible puis
tout jeune comme ça il me laissait aller
mais il se permettait de
me rappeler pas me rappeler à l'ordre le
même
ramener dans une certaine modestie à
tout coup je le dire dans mes rapports
avec eux il était très
très bon pour moi au début de ma
carrière puis
après j'aimais tellement ça c'est que je
vais tellement ça les spectacles j'aime
encore ceux puis on sait que je voulais
que ça dure enfin que j'ai vraiment fait
attention puis j'étais tombé sur des
bons compagnons de tournée on n'est pas
tombé dans cette espèce de je sais pas
de lancer son argent par les fenêtres ou
d'avoir un comportement
inapproprié il me semble la mer
monoparentale
meilleur date au monde
parce que la monoparentale a pas de
temps perdu là je vais me gâter parce
que je veux tout savoir sur mon numéro
préféré de Louis José Hood et lui dans
votre spectacle préfère novembre les
maires monoparentales d'où est venu
l'inspiration puis comment vous l'avez
créé ce gars qui est tellement ramassé
qui est tellement percutant oui oui ce
qui fout c'est que c'est un numéro qui
marchait très très bien et il était
facile à écrire je me rappelle ça c'est
niaiseux je donne à ma cuisine des fois
j'ai appris aussi que des fois les
bonnes idées arrivent pas nécessairement
à la table de travail juste quand je
parle à des plus jeunes je dis ça des
fois beaucoup parce que c'est fou
comment le cerveau est un peu tu vois
deux heures à ton bureau puis arrive
rien puis tu vas prendre une marche tout
de suite j'y pense à m'est arrivé ce
matin d'ailleurs et je te saoule la
douche et là faut que j'aille noter
quelque chose après notre entrevue j'ai
pas eu le temps de noter parce que je
m'en revenais ici on va prendre des
notes maintenant
pour mon prochain
tout le monde va tester
à l'envers en 2019 en fait à 41 ans
quand même j'ai rejoint les rangs des
célibataires dans une personne assez
pudique sur votre vie personnelle mais
vous vous êtes mis en danger avec votre
meilleur spectacle à vie je pense que
tout le monde s'entend là-dessus 1000
mauvais choix dans 1000 mauvais choix
vous parlez du temps qui passe vous
dites je vous cite lorsque j'éternue
trois fois faut que j'aille faire une
sieste
[Rires]
comment gardez-vous la forme justement
envers avec tous ces hauts et ses bases
d'un spectacle ça demande de l'énergie
monter sur 5 je fais attention à ma
condition physique ou Philippe
a emmené la course dans ma vie il était
difficile de faire du sport là organisé
ou à l'intérieur tout ça et puis j'ai
des amis et une sœur cadette qui m'ont
encouragé à courir et j'ai commencé ça
en pleine première vague et je poursuis
sûr depuis et puis c'est très heureux
comme résultat ça me je pense que ça
m'aide à faire mes spectacles avec avec
beaucoup d'énergie Louis José Aude vous
dites toujours que vous aimez tuer votre
public alors vous m'avez tué aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup avec plaisir vraiment
merci